TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
MEETING TO ORDER AMOUNTS AGREE
WE CALL THE ROLL FOR A QUORUM
[inaudible]
FRAZIER.
HERE FONG HERE AGUIAR-CURRY
[inaudible]
BAKER [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON HERE HARPER [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
NAZARIAN --
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
AYE WE'RE GOING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS
MEASURES ON CONSENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE S. YOUR ONE THIRTY
THREE WOULD ANY MEMBER LIKE --
TO MAKE MOST OF THE CONSENT
TELLING WILL.
I MISTER GIPSON OF MR MATHIS --
FIRST A SECOND MAN SURGERY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE
CONSECUTIVE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FRAZIER.
BY FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE CHU.
CHU AYE DALY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON GLORIA GIPSON
AYE HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS MATHIS I
MEDINA [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
CONSENT CALENDAR HAS ELEVEN
VOTES WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS --
WE HAVE MEASURES A FILE FINAL
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE AB ONE
SIXTY TWO CERVANTES HAS NOT BEEN
RETURNED FROM THE SENATE.
SO WE'LL MOVE THAT OFF FILE.
OF GONNA MOVE ON TO AB NINETY
ONE CERVANTES [inaudible]
FIRST BY.
BERMAN SECOND BY.
DAILY [inaudible]
REMIND -- SO
MOVE CERVANTES YET IN IRAQ OF
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT AB NINETY ONE I WANT TO
JUST BEGIN BY NOTING THAT
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
ARE MEANT TO STUDY THE
IMPLICATIONS --
OF THE BILL ON THE NINETY ONE IN
SIXTY FREEWAYS IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AT THIS BILL HAS
RECIPIENTS UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND IN THE SENATE
RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE AUTHORS BILL.
HE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THE
LIKE TO TESTIFY OR SHARE THEIR
OPINION.
OF THE AUTHORS BILL AGAINST WERE
OPPOSED.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
WOULD LIKE TO QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR.
WE HAVE A FIRST OR SECOND
ALREADY.
A CALLED MADAM SECRETARY OF SO
MEMBERS CERVANTES THANKS BRING
THE BILL FOR ALL BE SPORTING AS
I MENTIONED --
TO PLEASE KALRA.
THE MOTION IS THAT THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN
FRAZIER.
BY FRAZIER AYE FONG AYE FONG AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I A BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN I CHIU.
CHIU AYE DALY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE HARPER.
HOWEVER NOT VOTING MATHIS MATHIS
I MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL I THAT HAS TWELVE
LIBERAL UP ALL THE PREPS AND
MEMBERS ARE OUT.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ONTO ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY THREE THIRTY
BIGELOW.
MR WORK WAS --
HAS SENT A LETTER INTO THE CITY
PERCENT LOOKS LIKE HE'S NOT
HERE.
SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
INDIVIDUAL.
MR LAURIA AB THIRTY SIXTY ONE
ARE YOU PREPARED.
THE FIRST BY MR GETS A SECOND BY
MISTER BERMAN A REMIND YOU ARE
YOU ARE YOU HAVE AN I RECKON.
THAT'S YOUR AYE VOTE.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE AUTHORS BILL.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
LIKE TO TEST BY IN OPPOSITION.
TO THE AUTHORS BILL.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
HAVE QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
THEN.
MY SCHOOL WAS LIKE CLOSE BUT
BASS YOU AYE VOTE.
SO MOVIE GLORIA THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FOR TODAY
I'LL BE SUPPORTING IT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THAT THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG TONG AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN BERMAN I TO AYE
DALY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON GIPSON AYE
HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS MATHIS AYE
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL I THE BILL HAS
THIRTEEN LEAD ROLE OPEN FOR ANY
UPS A MEMBER.
GRADUATION BILLS OUT
[inaudible]
SO.
SURGES OF CALLING UP.
AUTHORS THE BILL'S
[inaudible]
MS DELGADO.
WITH S. B. TH.
SEVEN FIFTEEN PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY [inaudible]
THOUGH.
THE FIRST BY MR MEDINA SECOND BY
MISTER A GIPSON.
PLEASE PROCEED.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
SB SEVEN FIFTEEN SUPPORTS THE
CREATION OF LOCAL JOBS BY
ALLOWING CONSTRUCTION
APPRENTICES WHO OPERATE HEAVY
EQUIPMENT AND CRANES.
THE CONTINUED OPPORTUNITY TO
LEARN THEIR TRADE AND FURTHER
THEIR CAREERS.
AS YOU KNOW THE CALIFORNIA STATE
CARE BE HAS ADOPTED REGULATIONS
IN AN EFFORT TO REDUCE CARBON
EMISSIONS FROM IN USE OFF ROAD
DIESEL FUEL VEHICLES.
THANKS TO THESE MEASURES
CALIFORNIA HASCUT ANTHROPOGENIC
SOURCES OF BLACK CARBON
EMISSIONS BY MORE THAN 90% SINCE
THE NINETEEN SIXTIES.
AND WILL CUT THEM AGAIN IN HALF
BY.
TWENTY TWENTY THE AIR BE HAS
ACHIEVED THE SUCCESS AS WELL
ALSO CAREFULLY BALANCING THE
NEED FOR REASONABLE EXEMPTIONS
FROM THE STANDARDS.
STATE REGISTERED APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS USE OLDER HEAVY
EQUIPMENT TO REPAIR EMPLOYEES
FOR A CAREER IN THE CONSTRUCTION
TRADES.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
TRAINING EQUIPMENT AS YOU SICK
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS THAN
EQUIPMENT THAT IS USED ON A JOB
SITE.
I IT IS ESTIMATED THAT EQUIPMENT
IS A IN TRAINING IS USE
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED HOURS
PER YEAR OR FOUR HOURS PER WEEK.
AS COMPARED TO HEAVY EQUIPMENT
USE ON THE JOB SITE ANYWHERE
BETWEEN FIFTEEN HUNDRED AND
THREE THOUSAND HOURS ANNUALLY.
BUT THESE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS --
THAT OPERATE THE CRANES HAD TO
SPEND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
ORDER TO RETROFIT THEIR
EQUIPMENT TO COMPLY WITH THE
EXISTING REGULATIONS.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO RELIEVE THOSE
NOT NONPROFIT PROGRAMS FROM AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN EXPENSES --
WITH THE SIMILAR LOW USE
EXEMPTION FOR VEHICLES OWNED AND
OPERATED BY STATE REGISTERED
NONPROFIT APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS SIMILAR TO JOB CORPS.
A SIMILAR TO THE JOB CORPS
EXEMPTION.
IN THIS SCOPE OF THE OVERALL
STATEWIDE EMISSIONS INVENTORY
THE APPRENTICESHIP TRAINING
FLEET IS THE DEMAND A MESS.
CONTRIBUTOR BUT CRITICAL FOR
CREATING THESE JOBS S. B. SEVEN
FIFTEEN RESPECTS THE ACHIEVEMENT
OF ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS.
BUT ALSO WITH EMPLOYMENT
CREATION.
OF BOUNCING ALL THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY AND HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVENTEEN IS
TEMPERAMENTS WHAT THE OPERATING
ENGINEERS SOUTH OF THE US WITH
CALIFORNIA BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL.
AND MAKE A SCRIPT SCOTT MARLA
WITHDRAWAL CHO GREW.
SORRY ABOUT THAT I KNEW IT'S
GONNA TOP THAT UP [inaudible]
THE PLEASE.
BUT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THANKS FOR HEARING OR
BILL THE SLAY TIME GIVING UP
THIS BILL IT I THINK IT'S PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD IT'S AN ATTEMPT
TO OF AN EXEMPTION ENJOYED BY --
FOLKS OF SUCH AS THE JOB CORPS
OF THE ENTIRE AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY AND UTILITIES AND A
FIREFIGHTER APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS.
THESE THESE ARE.
PART TIME USE VEHICLES UP AND IN
YOUR MEMBER THERE YOU
SIGNIFICANT LESSON TRADITIONAL
CONSTRUCTION EQUIPMENT AND AT
LESS EXERTION RATES WE ARE ARE
PRETTY SHIP TRAINING EQUIPMENT
AVERAGES.
ROUGHLY A HUNDRED FIFTY THREE
HUNDRED HOURS YEARS IN USE AND
IT LESS EXERTION GREAT SO LET'S
ADMISSIONS IS WHAT THAT MEANS.
UP.
AND IN THE BILL IS CRAFTED FOR
ONLY THOSE TRAINING PROGRAMS
THAT ARE PART OF AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS SO THAT
NARROWS THE USE OF VEHICLES
BEING EXEMPTED ATOMIC --
ALSO ALSO IT'S WE BELIEVE THE
THE EXHAUSTIVE DE MINIMUS
COMPARED TO THE OVERALL UNIVERSE
ARE REGULATED VEHICLE.
UP AND IN.
WHAT WE STRUGGLE WITH THIS
REQUIREMENT OUR FLEETS HAVE TO
BE DIVERSE FLEETS AND UNLIKE A
CONTRACTOR WHERE THEY HAVE A
COUPLE PIECE OF EQUIPMENT OR
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS BECAUSE WE
HAVE TO TRAIN APPRENTICES ON
SEVERAL TYPES OF EQUIPMENT?
HAVE TO HAVE A DIVERSE FLEET AND
BECOMES A TOUGH REALLY TOUGH
BALANCING ACT WHERE YOU WHERE
YOU'RE MOVING EQUIPMENT IN AND
OUT OF SERVICE TO ACHIEVE
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS AND
TRAINING NEEDS.
AND IT IN THE THIRD JOINT LABOR
MANAGEMENT PROGRAMS KELLY.
IT'S AWESOME MANAGE IT WORKING
OTHER TO FIGURE OUT THE NEED TO
THE FUTURE AN THAN WHAT THERE
ARE PRESSING NEED TO BE TRAINED
UP. TO IT TO MAKE IT TO MAKE
THEM MORE EFFICIENT AND MORE
SAFE -- AS
AN EXAMPLE --
WE CURRENTLY HAVE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA FLEET OF HUNDRED
FOURTY FOUR VEHICLES FORTY ONE
OF THOSE VEHICLES ARE PUT IN
NINE YOU STATUS ARE LOW YOU
STATUS.
BECAUSE OF THE REGULATION AND
WHAT IS THAT MEANS THAT MEANS
OUR PRINCES HAVE LESS CHANCE TO
TRAIN ON THIS EQUIPMENT IT'S
LEAVING A HOLE IN OUR
CURRICULUM.
AND IT MAKES IT MAKES OUR OUR
CONTRACTORS AND OUR WORKERS
GENERAL LESS SAFE AND LEFT LEFT
EXPERIENCE.
OF IN IN IN AT ENTRANCE INTO --
WE SPENT FIVE TO SEVEN MILLION
UPGRADES IN THE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET WE
ANTICIPATE ANOTHER. SIX SEVEN
EIGHT MILLION TO BE INCOMPLETE
CHIEF COMPLIANCE [inaudible]
FOR FOR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
THE I IN IN THE END ON THE USE
OF OF EQUIPMENT THAT THE MARKET
WILL WILL DRIVE WHAT TYPE OF
EQUIPMENT WE TRAIN ON SO THE
MARKET WILL WILL DRIVE.
QUIT WITH ITS OUT OF USE OUT OF
DATE WILL BE TAKEN OF OUR OUT OF
OUR APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
THERE'S NO USE TO TRAIN APPROACH
APPRENTICES ON OLD DIRTY
EQUIPMENT --
AND I AND I HAVE THROUGH AN AYE
VOTE THING.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
NOT MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSUS OUR
HEELS OVER HALF THE STATE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL WANT THINK THE SENATOR
FOR CARRYING THIS IMPORTANT AND
VERY NARROW EXEMPTION FROM
IMPORTANT AIR REGULATION OF
RULES.
AS WAS STATED BY MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER CRIMMINS THESE ARE
PRIVATELY FUNDED APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS THAT ARE FUNDED
PRIMARILY BY WORKERS WAGES.
WE TRAIN THE BASS SKILLED BUT
THEY'RE ALSO VOWED RUN TO STATE
OF THE ART AS MUCH AS THEY CAN
IT MAKES SENSE THE GRANT IN THE
VERY NARROW EXEMPTION AS
PROVIDED TO OTHER INDUSTRIES AND
OTHER GROUPS IN CALIFORNIA FOR
THOSE REASONS WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
EXPERT KNIGHTLEY'S MIKHAIL
SCARLET HERE ON OF FROM THE BOOK
A GROUPIE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
ENVIRONMENT COME BALLOTS WERE
BUSINESS LABOR ORGANIZATION.
A SUPPORTING BOUNCE BETWEEN THE
ECONOMY AND THE ENVIRONMENT --
AS MENTIONED BY THE PREVIOUS --
SPEAKERS AT THIS IS A VERY
NARROW EXEMPTION OF MUCH
NARROWER THAN THE OTHER ONES
THAT AIR BECAUSE GRANTED IN
REGARDS TO THE LOW USE --
BUSES AND TRUCKS.
ACT EQUIPMENT THAT USE LESS THAN
50% OF THE TIME AND JOBS CORPSE
WHICH HAS A MUCH LARGER.
A FLEA AND THEY CO TRAINING AT
THE SAME FACILITIES --
WITH THAT WE APPRECIATE YOUR
EITHER.
THANK YOU NEITHER WITNESSES IN
THE PUBLIC IT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE AUTHORS
BILL.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
REPRESENTING PLEASE MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE ANY BERNACCHI MIGHT
HAPPEN NATIONAL ELECTRICAL
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA LEADS THE COMP
PLUMBING HEATING PIPING
INDUSTRY.
AND UNITED CONTRACTORS OR IN
SUPPORT OF THIS VERY IMPORTANT
INDUSTRY BILL THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
FAMOUS CHAIRMAN KEITH DONE HERE
ON BEHALF THE SUFFOLK COUNTIES
COALITION THE DISTRICT COUNCIL
OF IRON WORKERS THE SENATE
CALIFORNIA JUST LIKE TO SAY
THAT.
THIS TYPE OF PROGRAM IS CRITICAL
TO PROVIDE THE WORK FORCE THAT
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO MEET THE
DEMANDS OF OUR TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM.
HAVING THESE TRAINED AND SKILLED
EMPLOYEES TAKES TIME AND
RESOURCES.
AWAY FROM COST ON THESE PROJECTS
IS TO MINIMIZE COST ON WHAT
THEY'RE PUTTING OUT THERE AS FAR
AS THE OLDER VEHICLES IT'S A
GREAT PROGRAM WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT DON'T.
THINK YOUR NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
OR WILL THOMAS REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA LINES FOR JOBS THANK
YOU SENATOR FOR ADDRESSING THIS
CONCERN AND ASKING FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THE COMMITTEE.
IT'S ONE US PLEASE MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS CAN TONY
HIT AROUND WITH THE STATE
COUNCIL LABORERS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS EXEMPTION TO DO THE
OPPORTUNITIES PROVIDED BY OUR
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM THINK.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE PHILIP IF
ONE TO SOME OF THE ASSOCIATE
GENERAL COUNSEL.
ASSOCIATE ALL CONTRACTORS A
CALIFORNIA TRUSTS WORK
[inaudible]
THEY CAN.
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THERE
ARE TEST FINDS MORE THE AUTHORS
BILL.
SEEING NONE MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE AUTHORS BILL.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME IN THE
REPRESENTING PLEASE.
WELL GOOD EVENING HAVE WILL
PARENT WITH THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION WE
HAVE TO RESPECT PROPOSES BILL.
CALIFORNIA'S POLLUTION CONTROL
PROGRAMS ARE GROUNDED IN THE
PROTECTION PUBLIC HEALTH.
THIS BILL WOULD EXEMPT OLD LARGE
DIESEL ENGINES FROM IT INITIAL
CONTROL STANDARDS.
THE EXEMPTION PUTS TOXIC
CARCINOGENIC POLLUTION IN OUR
AIR THREATENS PUBLIC HEALTH
MAKES ATTAINMENT OF EMISSION
STANDARDS.
MORE DIFFICULT AND ULTIMATELY
COULD SHIFT EMISSION REDUCTIONS
TO OTHER SOURCES.
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
HAS DECLARED DIESEL EXHAUST IS
CARCINOGENIC CALIFORNIA A STATE
RECOGNIZES DIESEL EXHAUST AS A
TOXIC AIR CONTAMINANT.
ALLOWING THIS EXEMPTION PUTS THE
HEALTH OF HEALTH OF WORKERS
TRAINEES AND SURROUNDING
NEIGHBORS AT RISK.
WE DON'T KNOW THE SCOPE OF THE
VEHICLE FLEET THE OPERATING LE
SITE LOCATIONS OUR NEIGHBORING
LAND USES.
OR OTHER CRITICAL DETAILS WOULD
HELP US TO EVALUATE THIS
LEGISLATION.
WE'RE CONCERNED THAT THIS
EXEMPTION WOULD BREATHE NEW LIFE
INTO.
EQUIPMENT THAT WOULD EITHER BE
OTHERWISE BE RETIRED.
BOB WE APPRECIATE THAT THIS
COMMITTEE HAS REJECTED PAST
EFFORTS TO EXEMPT EQUIPMENT FROM
ADMISSIONS REQUIREMENTS IN THE
PAST AND REQUESTED OF THE SENATE
TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
AYE MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
BRING INTO IT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION.
AYE REPRESENTING ALL THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER SMALL THIRTY
FIVE LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS OUT
WERE ALSO RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION AND CERTAINLY WE
APPRECIATE THE VALUE OF THE
APPRENTICESHIP.
TRAINING PROGRAMS BUT WE ARE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH IMPACT RELATED THIS
ANSWER MISTER BARRETT HAS
MENTIONED --
WERE ALSO TALKING ABOUT.
THE APPRENTICE APPRENTICES ARE
BREATHING --
HIGH CONCENTRATION OF CANCER
CAUSING DIESEL PARTICULATE
MATTER A AND THAT IS OUR CONCERN
IN ADDITION TO THE NEARBY
COMMUNITIES --
I WILL POINT OUT THAT THIS
REGULATION HAS BEEN ON THE BOOKS
SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN OF V..
AT DEADLINE TO COMPLY AND IS
JANUARY --
ONE TWENTY NINETEEN IT'S BEEN
POINTED OUT THAT THERE HAVE BEEN
OTHER EXEMPTIONS UP LIKE THE JOB
CORPS PROGRAM BUT THAT IS
DIFFERENT IN THAT IT WENT
THROUGH.
THE PUBLIC PROCESS THE
REGULATORY PROCESS AND THAT'S
ONE OF OUR BIG CONCERNS WITH ALL
OF THIS IS THAT A A THAT TO US
IS IS A WHERE SOMETHING LIKE
THIS SHOULD BE RESOLVED IN
THERE'S OPPORTUNITY THERE TO DO
THAT.
AND WE THINK THIS SETS A BAD
PRECEDENT WHERE --
IF.
OTHERS WILL BE COMING TO THE
LEGISLATURE OUGHT TO DO THE SAME
THING AND THAT'S ALSO GOING TO
HAVE ADDITIONAL PUBLIC HEALTH
IMPACT.
I WILL.
ALSO ADD THAT I'M.
THEY'RE THEY'RE OUR INCENTIVE
GRANTS AVAILABLE THAT POSSIBLY
COULD HAVE BEEN USED FOR THIS AS
WELL. TO HELP --
BUT HERE WE ARE AT THE AT THE
ELEVENTH HOUR RIGHT BEFORE THE
DEADLINE.
AND THAT WE RESPECTFULLY.
OPPOSE THE MEASURE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ASTEP UP THE MIKE PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME AND WHO YOU REPRESENT
PLACE.
I THANK YOU A DANTE ACOSTA
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THIRTY EIGHTH
DISTRICT --
I WAS HERE IN FRONT OF THIS
COMMITTEE --
JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO ROB
RECENTLY HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CONSIDER OF THE BILL THAT I
AUTHORED AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
FIVE THAT WOULD HAVE INCLUDED
THE VERY FOLKS OF THAT THIS BILL
SEEKS TO HELP.
BUT INSTEAD OF TREATING EVERY A
CRANE OPERATOR AND OWNER IN
CALIFORNIA THE SAME --
OF THIS BILL --
WAS THAT BILL WAS REJECTED BY
THIS BODY AND I THINK THAT --
THIS COMMITTEE SHOULD DEFINITELY
REJECT THIS BILL ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT --
IS SEWING COMPANY IS AS A
LEGISLATURE AND ALL THE U. S.
LEGISLATORS IS A FAIRNESS ASPECT
TO IT -- IF
THE REGULATION IS --
IF THIS REGULATIONS BAD FOR THE
OPERATING ENGINEERS AND THEIR
PREMISE PRO OF APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM AND TO BE CLEAR I THINK
THAT IT IS --
ONEROUS REGULATION THAT IT'S
ALSO BAD FOR THE BUSINESSES THAT
HIRE THE VERY PEOPLE THAT THIS
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM IS
[inaudible]
TRAINING --
I HAVE A AGAIN OPERATOR MY
DISTRICT CHAMPION CRANE WHO HAS
UP FOLKS THERE WORKING A
THROUGHOUT THE DISTRICTS IN THE
VALLEY.
ARM THAT ARE HIGHERS THE
OPERATING ENGINEERS MEMBERS AND
THIS BILL DOES NOTHING FOR THEM
AS A MATTER OF FACT THAT
BUSINESSES RIGHT ON THE VERGE OF
GOING OUT OF GOING OUT OF
BUSINESS SO I URGE YOU TO REACT
A REJECT THIS HALF MEASURE.
AND I REALLY ENCOURAGE THE THE
LEGISLATURE TO COME BACK IN THIS
COMMITTEE TO COME BACK AND WORK
ON MEANINGFUL LEGISLATION THAT
BENEFITS ALL CALIFORNIANS AND
TREATS THEM EQUALLY.
ARE BECAUSE THE VERY ENGINEERS
THAT THIS PROGRAM WANTS TO TRAIN
WILL COME BACK IN THE CALIFORNIA
AND FIND OUT THAT THEY WILL NOT
HAVE THE JOBS THAT THESE --
THAT OTHER TRAINING FOR AND I
THINK THAT'S REALLY AN ISSUE AND
IT'S ALSO AN ISSUE LIKE I SAID
EARLIER OF COME OF FAIRNESS.
AND I THINK WE NEED TO REJECT
HYPOCRISY THAT THIS BILL
ACTUALLY JUST THROWS RIGHT UP IN
OUR FACE BECAUSE IT'S A IT'S AN
ABSOLUTE --
YOU KNOW HYPOCRITICAL MOVED TO
SAY THAT THE COMPANY IS SIR IS
IS IT'S GOT UP MEET THE SUBJECT
IS BUT NOT THE ACTUAL --
ORGANIZATION SO I APPRECIATE
THAT YOUR TIME AND I APPRECIATE
THE INDULGENCE OF THE CHAIR
WHILE THE LONG THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AND HE REPRESENT PLEASE.
TOM EDISON WITH THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
HEARD AND BEHALF OF IRAQ TO
EXECUTIVE OFFICER RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THE BILL.
WE THINK THAT BELONGS OF
APPRENTICES IMPORTANT TOO WE
THINK THAT APPRENTICES SHOULD BE
TRAINING ON NEW CLEAN EQUIPMENT
NOT OLD DIRTY EQUIPMENT --
WE WOULD NOTE THAT THIS BILL AS
PROPOSED.
UNFORTUNATELY DOES NOT GRANT.
I TIME EXTENSION OF FOR
COMPLIANCE ELIMINATES COMPLIANCE
ENTIRELY WE WOULD NOTE THAT THE
TWO THOUSAND AND SEVEN
REGULATION.
SETS UP COMPLIANCE PERIOD THAT
STARTS IN TWENTY NINETEEN BUT
THAT'S ONLY FOR THE FIRST.
OUR INITIAL PORTION OF VEHICLES
VEHICLES HAVE UNTIL TWO THOUSAND
AND TWENTY EIGHT ARE THERE ARE
BEING EXEMPTED FROM THIS RULE TO
COMPLY.
ARM FOR THOSE REASONS WE'VE BUT
TACTFULLY OPPOSE.
ISSUE NAMELY REPRESENT PLEASE
HER ROCKY RUSHING WITH COLLEGE
FOR CLEAN AIR IN APRIL OF THIS
YEAR WHEN THIS COMMITTEE
REJECTED.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ACOSTA IS BILL
--
HE DID THE RIGHT THING AND IN
PART THE ANALYSIS READ BY
EXEMPTING ONE CATEGORY OF
VEHICLE FROM EXISTING
REGULATIONS WE ARE UNDERMINING
OUR STATE CALLS AND POTENTIALLY
WE OPENING REGULATIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN IN PLACE FOR OVER A DECADE.
THE ANALYSIS WENT ON TO READ
ADDITIONALLY PROVIDING EXEMPTION
FOR ONE CATEGORY MAY PRESUMABLY
LEAD TO OTHER INDUSTRIES.
COMING BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE
TO SEEK EXEMPTION.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND CENTER
DELGADO WE THINK THE COMMITTEE
GOT IT RIGHT BACK THEN WE HOPE
COMMITTEE GETS IT RIGHT TONIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
ELECT TESTIFYING OPPOSITION THE
AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE MISTER FUNG.
I WOULD APPRECIATE YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD --
AND CERTAINLY I'M SYMPATHETIC
THAT WE NEED WEAPONS OR RELIEF
--
BUT OF COURSE AS AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER --
ACOSTA MENTION I'M AS THESE
GRADUATES LEAVE PAPERS ARE
PROGRAMS WE CERTAINLY WANT PRINT
OPERATORS TO HIRE THEM.
SO HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THAT
FACT THAT AND WE ARE PROVIDING
AN EXEMPTION FOR THESE --
OPPRESSOR PROGRAMS BUT THEN THE
CRANE OPERATORS AT LARGE WHETHER
THEY BE UNION OR NOT --
THEY ARE HAVING THESE OWNERS
REGULATE TO AND TOUR AND THEY
MAKE A LOT OF BUSINESS AND SO
THE JOB MARKET ISN'T GONNA BE
THERE FOR THEM.
IF I MAY I I THINK WE ALL
UNDERSTAND THIS IS A A MUCH
NARROWER PROPOSITION THAN THE
BILL ITSELF REFERENCE IN THE
PATH.
AND ALMOST A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT POLICY QUESTION.
OF BUT I WOULD SAY IN CURRENT
PRACTICE NOW WE HAVE SEVERAL
CONTRACTORS OR SIGNATORY TO US.
WERE WORKING AND THRIVING THAT
WE ARE THE BUSINESS WE'VE BEEN
AND IT DECADES AND THEY CONTINUE
TO THRIVE UNDER THE CURRENT
REGULATIONS.
HOW MANY GRADUATES WOULD PER
YEAR WOULD THAT WEIGH IN ON THAT
AND THAT VARIES DRAMATICALLY
DEPENDING ON THE ECONOMY --
WE ARE PROBABLY SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA RUNNING. EIGHT
HUNDRED NINE HUNDRED GRADUATES
AND PLAVI IS SOMEWHAT OF A LIKE
NUMBER AND IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
AND HOW MANY OF THEM GET PLACE
AFTER THEY GRADUATE OF THEY ALL
DO IT ALL THE BILL WE WERE
ACTUALLY LOOKING FOR APPRENTICES
NOW WE CAN'T FIND THEM.
IN FOR SEVERANCE WE HAVE
OPENINGS WERE DYING TO FIND
APPRENTICES NOW.
BUT BUT I AND IT'S GREAT AND AT
WITH THE SENATOR A GREAT THAT
THERE IS THAT THE THAT THIS
REGULATION IS.
FAIRLY ONEROUS ON NOT ONLY
DEPEND SHIP TAKE ON THE UNION
PROGRAM OTHER PRODUCER PROGRESS
BUT ALSO ON THE CRANE OPERATORS
AT LARGE IN YOUR DISTRICT.
AT THIS POINT I'M SEEKING TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE FOR THE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM FOR JOB
CREATION THAT'S WHERE IN DIRE
NEED IN THE STATE FOR THE BUT
ACCEPTING THIS BILL WOULD ALSO
ACCEPT THE PREMISE THAT.
THAT THIS THAT THIS CAR
REGULATION IS ONEROUS WELL ON
THE OBOE THEY WE NO REASON FOR
THE FOR THE EXEMPTION --
IF I MAY UM AYE AYE WOULD
RESPOND --
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS NOTICE
OWNERS BUT THE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS ARE REALLY UNIQUE IN
THAT THEY HAVE A VERY DIVERSE.
FLEET THAT HAVE TO TO MAINTAIN
TO TRAIN NOT.
A TRADITIONAL CONTRACTOR HAS
ABOUT THREE OR FOUR SPECIFIC
EQUIPMENT HE CAN RUN THROUGH WE
HAVE TO HAVE EVERY PIECE.
EQUIPMENT IN THE CATALOG SO WE
HAVE A DIVERSIFIED WELL TRAINED
WORKFORCE SO TILL IT'S A LITTLE
BIT THE RATE OF A AFFECT OUR
PROGRAMS IN A DIFFERENT WAY.
THAN A TRADITIONAL CONTRACTOR
HOUSE UP.
I WOULD JUST VENTURE TO SAY THAT
THE LEG THAT THIS BILL IT'S A
BIT SMALL ITSELF IS CONSISTENT
WITH.
SIMILAR EXEMPTIONS TO JOB CORPS
EXEMPTION ALREADY MAKES THE SAME
DETERMINATION THAT THIS IS AN
ONEROUS REQUIREMENT FOR CERTAIN
PROGRAMS SO.
THIS ALREADY IS BEING DONE AND
WE ARE JUST SEEKING THIS VERY
MINOR.
A EXEMPTION FOR THIS PROGRAM
WOULD YOU BE OPENED LAST
QUESTION OF APOLOGIZED I WOULD
VISITORS WOULD YOU BE OPEN TO
EXPANDING THE EXEMPTION FOR
CRANE OPERATORS --
BROADLY IN THE FUTURE.
SO I THINK I THINK WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IS AN INCREDIBLY
NARROW EXAM FOR THE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM WHICH IS
NOT GENERATING REVENUE RIGHT.
YOU'RE TRAINING PEOPLE IT'S LIKE
GOING TO COLLEGE AND YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO GIVE THEM A NEW MILLION
DOLLAR PIECE OF EQUIPMENT TO TO
TRAIN ON UNTIL IT'S YOU KNOW IT
THIS IS HAND ME DOWN FROM THE
CONTRACTORS THIS IS NOT.
BRAND NEW IN FLEET STUFF THAT
YOU'RE GONNA BE RUNNING YOU
KNOW.
THREE SHIFTS A DAY PERK FOR ROAD
PROJECT IN AND TO INVEST THAT
CAPITAL.
IN SOMETHING THAT THAT'S ONLY
GONNA GET TWO HUNDRED HOURS OF
USE IN A YEAR WOULD BE.
IT IT JUST DOESN'T MAKE ANY
FINANCIAL SENSE --
AND I THINK THAT'S WHY THE JOB
CORPS.
WOULD RECEIVE THEIR EXEMPTION IT
IT.
YOU KNOW TO APPLY THIS TO TO TWO
HUNDRED OR LESS IN TWO HUNDRED
VEHICLES THAT.
ARE USED FOR LESS THAN TWO
HUNDRED HOURS IS FAIRLY
REASONABLE IN TERMS OF ALSO
LIMITED. TO TO TO GO TO OUR
THREE LOCATIONS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SOME OF THESE
LOCATIONS ARE CROWE TRAINED WITH
JOBS CORPS.
AND THEY'RE EXEMPT EQUIPMENT
SHIRTS AYE I I I ACCEPT THE
PREMISE BEHIND THE THE BILL I
JUST WANT TO ENSURE THAT WHEN
THESE GRADUATES OF THESE
PROGRAMS.
GO ENTERED THE WORKFORCE THAT
ONE ISSUE THAT THERE ARE MORE
CRANE OPERATORS --
AT THAT ARE AVAILABLE AND
DRIVING TO HIRE THESE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM OR THEIR
BODIES GRADUATES AND SO MY HOPE
IS THAT IF WE COULD PROVIDE SOME
CERTAINTY IN SOME REGULATORY
CERTAINTY FOR THESE UP.
CRANE OPERATORS IN THE BUSINESS
CLIMATE IN CALIFORNIA THAT THEY
WERE ABLE.
TO HIRE MORE THESE GRADUATES AND
SO THAT WE WOULD HAVE MORE
GRADUATES WE HAVE MORE EMPLOYEES
SO I I APPRECIATE THE TIME THAT
IT TOOK BECAUSE OTHER THAN THAT
--
THIS IS A CRITICAL ISSUE AS FAR
AS IT RELATES TO JOB CREATION I
AM FORTUNATELY M. IN THE
LEGISLATOR LEGISLATION ONLY FOR
ANOTHER WEEK SO I AM TRYING TO
ACHIEVE SOMETHING.
OF FOR THE PEOPLE WORKING PEOPLE
IN MY COMMUNITY [inaudible]
I REQUEST [inaudible]
MISTER NAZARIAN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD
EVENING BY THE WAY [inaudible]
AB.
IS THERE A MOTION TO MOVE THIS
BILL.
AND THE SECOND.
I JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE THANK
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL CHEN
QUIT BUT YOU KNOW THE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRED SWIMMING QUICK
COMMENT I'M HERE FOR JOBS YOU
FOR JOB TRAINING YOUR FOR THIS
BILL.
I APPRECIATE THOSE BILLS BEEN
NARROWLY TARIFF TAILORED TO
ADDRESS A CERTAIN SITUATION AND
THAT IS A JOB TRAINING
SITUATION.
AND IT COMPLIMENTS OTHER --
LIKE POLICY --
NOW IT MISTER COST YOU BROUGHT
OF A BILL THAT YOU HAD NIGHT I
MENTIONED AFTER YOU BROUGHT THAT
BILL FOR THAT I'D LIKE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT BUT
THAT.
THAT IS A DIFFERENT CONVERSATION
THAT WE'RE HAVING TODAY --
AND THAT IS A CONVERSATION
INVOLVES MANY STAKEHOLDERS MANY
AT THIS TABLE NOW NOT PROMISING
ANYTHING OTHER THAN I AM OPEN TO
HAVING THAT CONVERSATION.
BUT JUST FOR THE SENATOR I DO
APPRECIATE THIS NARROWLY
TAILORED BILL THAT YOU PRESENTED
TODAY THANK YOU.
THINK ANY OTHER QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE MS BAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THANK YOU SENATOR IBM SINCE OUR
FIRST HAS ALWAYS MAKES IT.
I APPRECIATE THAT I I HAVE
CONSIDER I WANNA MAKE SURE THIS
APPLIES TO ALL OF MY
CONSTITUENTS TO HAVE A COULD
APPLY I CARE ABOUT THEIR JOBS IN
MY DISTRICT.
AND THE WAY THIS IS WRITTEN IT
DOESN'T.
AND SO I I WELCOME UNDERSTANDING
A LITTLE BIT MORE FROM YOU --
WHY NOT INCLUDE MORE BROADLY ALL
THE OPERATORS OF THE VERY --
TYPES OF VEHICLES AND IN
SPECIFICALLY WHAT IS IT ABOUT A
FORKLIFT THAT'S OPERATED BY.
YOU KNOW A UNION RELATED A
PROGRAM CAN ONE THAT ISN'T
BECAUSE THEY THEY ARE THE SAME
THE WORKER IN MY DISTRICT IS IS
THE SAME THAT BUSINESS IN MY
DISTRICT THAT IS WORKING WITH
BUT THEM AS WELL AS UNION
MEMBERS IS THE SAME.
AND THE AIR WE BREATHE AT ALL OF
THAT AND SO.
WHAT IS DIFFERENT ABOUT THE
TYPES OF VEHICLES A VERY
SPECIFIC QUESTION THE VEHICLES
THAT THIS DOES APPLY?
TO AND IF YOU'RE NOT UNION THAT
IT DOESN'T.
AND I'M INTERESTED IN THE
SENATOR'S RESPONSE ACTUALLY SO
THIS ACTUALLY SIX AN EXEMPTION
FOR STATE REGISTERED NON
PROFITS.
WHO ARE SEEKING TO CREATE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS SO
THERE'S NO SPECIFIC UNION
DESIGNATION FOR IT OTHER COULD
BE OTHER LIKE A PROGRAMS THAT
COULD SEEK THE SAME EXEMPTION?
UNDER YOUR ARE YOUR BILL STATE
REGISTERED NONPROFIT NONPROFIT
APPRENTICESHIP TRAINING PROGRAM
SO ARE THERE ARE OPERATORS OF
GRADERS LOADERS MOWERS ROLLERS
ROUGH TERRAIN FORKLIFTS READ
TIRE LOADERS SCRAPERS.
SKID STEER LOADERS AND THESE
OTHERS THAT ARE NON.
THAT ARE ARE NOT COVERED BY THIS
THAT ARE IN APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM THAT WOULD NOT BE
COVERED BY THIS BILL OF YOURS
JUST MAKING SURE WE UNDERSTAND
THE TEXT OF THE BILL.
I'M SIZE REPEAT YOUR QUESTION
SO.
I I I WANNA MAKE SURE I'M
UNDERSTANDING YOU CORRECTLY
[inaudible]
THAT.
THEY SOMEONE COULD APPLY FOR
THIS.
THAT OPERATES ANYONE OF THE
VEHICLES TO WHICH THE SUPPLIES
THROUGH AND THEY'VE LEARNED
THROUGH THE PRESSURE PROGRAM
BECAUSE I HAVE THOSE IN MY AREA
IN THE BAY AREA AS WELL.
YOU MADE IT SOUND LIKE THEY
COULD APPLY FOR IT.
TOO IF THEY ARE STATE RUN JUST A
STATE REGISTER NONPROFIT
APPRENTICESHIP TRAINING PROGRAM
OKAY SO WHAT APPRENTICESHIP
TRAINING PROGRAMS ARE NOT
COVERED BY THE BILL.
ONES THAT ARE NOT STATE REGISTER
NONPROFITS OF WORK DO YOU KNOW
WHERE THEY ARE WHERE THEY'RE
LOCATED.
I'D I DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE A
LIST ARE YOU AWARE AYE AYE IF I
MAY.
UM.
SO THE AGAIN THE THESE ARE
PROGRAMS REGISTER WITH
CALIFORNIA STATE APPRENTICESHIP
COUNCIL GENERALLY MOST OF THEM
ARE IT CERTAINLY IS THE
INDUSTRY'S AT THE DO THE BULK OF
THE APPRENTICESHIP TRAINING THE
HEAVY EQUIPMENT INDUSTRY.
ART JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT
COMMITTEES MEETING THEY HAVE
SEVERAL EMPLOYERS AND THAT AND
THAT'S WHAT MAKES OUR
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS UNIQUE.
YOU'RE SERVING SEVERAL EMPLOYERS
ENOUGH HAVE SEVERAL PIECES OF
EQUIPMENT IS WHAT MAKES IT I
THINK WHAT YOU'RE REFERRING TO
IF I MAY IS PROBABLY SINGLE
EMPLOYER TRAINING PROGRAMS
[inaudible]
GENERALLY --
I I WOULD ARGUE THAT'S A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENT OR SINGLE EMPLOYER
WILL MULTI EMPLOYER YOU HAVE TO
HAVE A DIVERSITY OF ADVERSE
FRIENDSHIP AND A DIVERSE
CONTRACTOR BAKER SERVING.
AS OPPOSED TO SINGLE EMPLOYERS
ONE TYPE OF INDUSTRY GENERALLY
LIMITED NUMBER OF EQUIPMENT
THEIR TRAINING AT THE END FOR
AND FOR THE SENATE AS WELL AS IT
IS YOUR BILL YOUR NAME IS ON IT
AND YOU ARE DOING IT FOR YOUR
CONSTITUENTS I'M ALSO THINKING
OF MINE AND OTHER.
CALIFORNIANS.
WHAT IS DIFFERENT ABOUT THE
VEHICLES THAT THEY ARE
OPERATING?
THE ONES THAT ARE COVERED BY
THIS BILL.
THAT ARE --
FOR THOSE WHO CAN'T APPLY.
WHY SHOULD THEY BE TREATED
DIFFERENTLY?
WHY SHOULD THIS GROUP RETRAITE
TREATED DIFFERENTLY YES?
REALLY THE GOVERNMENT VEHICLES
LIKE BECAUSE OF MY UNDERSTANDING
IS YOU SAY THAT'S A HAND ME DOWN
COMING FROM A CONTRACTOR YOU CAN
DO THAT AND AND OTHER TRAINING
PROGRAMS WHAT'S DIFFERENT ABOUT
THAT VEHICLE.
THAT IF I IF I MAY SAY SO CARPET
DOESN'T ON A FLEET AVERAGE.
NOT PER NOT PER VEHICLE ON THE
ON THE ENTIRE FLEET A IN YOUR
POSSESSION WHETHER.
YOU'RE IN YOUR SINGLE EMPLOYER
WHETHER YOU'RE AN APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM.
YOUR YOUR CARBS STANDARD IS
DETERMINED BY YOUR ENTIRE FLEET
AVERAGE IT'S IT'S NOT THE
EQUIPMENT OKAY SO.
UP THE AIR I STILL TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND BECAUSE I'M I'M GONNA
BE ABLE TO GO BACK TO MY
CONSTITUENTS AND SAY WHY IT'S
OKAY TO CARVE SOME OF THEM OUT
AND NOT ALLOW OTHERS TO HAVE THE
BENEFIT AND WHENEVER I THINK%
THEY'VE GIVEN YOU AN ANSWER I
THINK GOING. TO GET THE SAME
ANSWER.
WELL I'M ASKING THAT ANSWER FOR
THE QUESTIONS.
LET ME WOULDN'T LET ME
INTERJECT.
SO ACTUAR WAS RIGHT THE MILITA
QUESTION THE GO AHEAD MISTER
CHAIR YEAH OKAY THANK YOU SO
VIVID EXPLAIN TO YOU THAT THESE
ARE HAND ME DOWN VEHICLES.
OR EQUIPMENT THEY DON'T HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO MAKE MONEY OFF THIS
LIKE PRIVATE INDUSTRY.
SO THEY HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
UTILIZE THE EQUIPMENT AND TELL.
ITS EXPIRES OKAY.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
MAKE A DIME OFF OF THIS.
PRIVATE INDEED DOES THEY
TRANSFER ANY COST ON TO THE
CONSUMER.
THEY ARE PRIVATELY FUNDED BY
EMPLOYEES [inaudible]
DUES SO THIS IS THIS IS THERE
FUNDING MECHANISM.
THEY WILL THE HUBBY.
UTILIZING ANYTHING OTHER THAN
THIS EQUIPMENT FOR TRAINING.
NOT NOT MAKING MONEY SO THAT'S
WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I I'D YOU
HAVING VISIT SOME OF THE
LOCATIONS FOR APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS IN MY DISTRICT I DO
UNDERSTAND THAT COMPONENT
BECAUSE I I DO TRY TO GO IN.
AND SEE THE STUFF FOR MYSELF AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S DIFFICULT FOR
ME IN A AND I HEARD THE
TESTIMONY THAT.
WITHOUT THIS WORKERS WILL BE
LESS SAFE AND LESS EXPERIENCED
AND I'M MORE INTERESTED IN
WHEREVER THE WORKER IS WHAT
WHATEVER.
YOU KNOW EQUIPMENT FLEET THEIR
TRAINING ON THAT THEY'RE TREATED
EQUALLY.
AND THEY HAVE THE SAME EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY IN BENEFITS ARE
COMING FROM THIS BILL THAT'S THE
CONCERN THAT I HAVE ABOUT IT AND
AYE I KNOW YOU WORK PART OF THE
BACKSTORY ON WHY THERE WAS A
BILL EARLIER THIS YEAR AND WHOSE
NAME GETS ON AND I ADMIRE THAT
YOU.
IN THE TIME THAT YOU GET TO
SERVE IN THE BODY ARE ABLE TO
WANT TO COME FOR IT IT'S JUST
THAT IT'S LEAVING OUT SOME OF MY
CONSTITUENTS THEY APPRECIATE
YOUR CONCERNS.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE --
CENTER WE'D LIKE CLOSE.
AB MEMBERS THIS BILL SIMPLY
PROVIDES AN EXEMPTION --
LIKE PROVIDED FOR THE JOB CORPS
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM --
FOR THIS A SIMILAR GROUP AND IT
WILL HELP CREATE MUCH NEEDED
JOBS IN OUR STATE SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR BRING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND AGAIN AS A BY
PRODUCT THE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM IS A CARPENTER I
APPRECIATE.
THE EFFORTS OF VIEWING AND THE
US SUPPORTERS OF THIS STE TO
CONTINUE [inaudible]
BRINGING.
QUALITY TRAINING TO THE
WORKFORCE ON ANY KIND OF MEANS
POSSIBLE TO GET THEM OUT GOING
FOR IS IS.
GRAHAM IS A STATED WE NEED MORE
PEOPLE A WE'VE GOT A LOT OF WORK
NOW.
AND WE DON'T PUT ANY MORE
CONSTRAINTS ON THE OPPRESSION
PROGRAMS THAT WE NEED.
TO I WITH THAT'LL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL TODAY HOW WE HAVE THIS
FIRST BY MR MEDINA SECOND BY
MISTER GIPSON.
AND SECRETARY PLEASE CULTURAL
IMMERSION IS DO PASS FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG NO
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BAKER BAKER NO
BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE DALY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON --
GIPSON AYE HARPER.
HARPER NO MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE O'DONNELL O'DONNELL
AYE.
YOUR BILL HAS TEN LEAVE THE ROLE
PLAYING CASES IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS --
CONGRATULATIONS CENTER IN YOUR
* ALTHOUGH MINDS.
WATCH OUT FOR THE HAZING ON THE
FLOOR.
SO WE ARE IN THIS MISTER BELL
IS.
RUNNING BEHIND OVER THE SENATE
SOMEONE TO TRANSFER THE GAVEL
OVER TO MR FUNG.
WELL THAT THEY'LL [inaudible]
DID [inaudible]
WITH DIFFERENT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN YOU CAN SAY
WHATEVER YOU WANT
[inaudible]
YOU MEMBERS [inaudible]
CHAIR.
I'M OFFERING AB THIRTY ONE
THIRTY FIVE TO FINAL WHAT
FINALLY PART PRIOR TOYS.
SUSAN PRIORITIZE SAFETY ON OUR
HIGHWAY SYSTEM.
THE FACTS ARE CLEAR SINCE TWO
THOUSAND TEN THE STATE'S
HIGHWAYS HAVE BECOME LESS SAFE.
SPECIFICALLY CRASHES HAVE
INCREASED 29%.
OF THE NUMBER OF DEATHS PER MILE
DRIVEN HAS INCREASED 27%.
THE STATISTICS FAR OUTPACE THE
STATE'S POPULATION GROWTH OF 8%.
AND AS WELL AS INCREASE OF
LICENSED DRIVERS ARE REGISTERED
VEHICLES OF 11%.
THE DECLINING SAFETY OF OUR
HIGHWAYS IS DIRECTLY RELATED TO
THIS FACT.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TEN THE
NUMBER OF CHP OFFICERS ON OUR
ROADS HAS ACTUALLY DECREASED BY
7%.
IT IS TIME FOR THE STATE TO TAKE
ACTION TO REVERSE THESE TRENDS
IMPROPERLY FUND THE OFFICERS WE
NEED TO ENSURE.
CALIFORNIA'S CAN TRAVEL SAFELY
AND PROTECT.
OUR LOVED ONES.
AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY FIVE
REQUIRES THE GOVERNOR TO
PRIORITIZE THE FUNDING WE
COLLECT FOR ENFORCING HIGHWAY
SAFETY LAWS.
AND SPEND IT AS IT SHOULD BE
SPENT [inaudible] ONE OFFICERS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IDOL.
I WAS GONNA GIVE A WITNESS IS
THE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AARON READ REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION I'VE A
PROMISE I DON'T KNOW OF ANYBODY
IN THIS LEGISLATURE THIS MORE
PASSIONATE.
ABOUT HIGHWAY SAFETY.
THEN.
YOU'RE CHAIRMAN HERE MISTER
FRASER A I CAN ADD ANYTHING TO
WHAT HE SAID WE WE ARE VERY SAD
THAT THE DEATH RATE IS UP
CRASHES ARE UP.
AND NUMBER OF OFFICERS DOWN BY
OVER FOUR HUNDRED IT'S IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THAT NEEDS TO BE
FIXED.
THANK YOU SELIGER WITH YOU ANY
OTHER.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OF IS MUCH A CLOTHES WASHER AB
SIDE WITH ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
YEAH THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD I'M WITH ALL THE
DEVASTATION WE'VE SEEN WITH ALL
THE FIRES ISSUES I DIDN'T
REALIZE --
HOW MUCH TIME AND HOW --
THIS A CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
OWES VERY --
PRESIDENT ALL OF OUR FIRES AND
THE IMPORTANCE OF HAVING THEM
THERE AND SO I REALIZED THEY HAD
TO BE FOR SPREAD REALLY THIN SO
I I APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
FORWARD THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS
THAT CLOSE THINKING THIS
FEATURE.
TWO WEEKS AGO I ATTENDED A
FUNERAL FOR OFFICER KIRK GRIP
RICE GRIS.
WITH THIS ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAVE
YOUR CURRY --
DISTRACTED DRIVING WAS THE CAUSE
OF THE DEATH OF THE OFFICER AND
THAT'S BECOMING MORE PREVALENT
ON THE HIGHWAYS.
GOING THROUGH OF PAYING ALL OF
US ARE DRIVING WE SEE PEOPLE IN
THEIR PHONES AND TEXTING AND
DRIVING.
THESE CAN BE A DETERRENCE WITH
OFFICERS A IN PLACE [inaudible]
OF I I'M HERE AS A FATHER WHO
LOST A CHILD IN IT HIGH WEEKLY.
CAR ACCIDENT ASKING FOR YOUR
SUPPORT IS SENDING A STRONG
MESSAGE TO THE ADMINISTRATION
THAT WE MUST.
REINSTATE OFFICERS IN THE
HIGHWAY PATROL.
I RESPECTFULLY ANSWERABLE.
I THINK HE WAS CHAIRMAN HAS AYE
AYE DADDY MISTER REED SAID IT
BEST YOU ARE AN ADVOCATE FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY ON OUR ROADS AND
THERE IS NO GREATER ADVOCATE
THING YOU SO WE HAVE A MOTION OF
BYE.
BYE MISTER GIPSON AND A SECOND
BY MISTER MATHIS AMOUNTS ACUTELY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION ARE IS THAT THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED
IN FRAZIER AYE AYE FRAZIER AYE
FONG.
FONG AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN BERMAN I CHIU
AYE DALY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AYE GIPSON AYE GIPSON
AYE HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MEDINA.
MEDINA INEZ AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL I THOSE FOURTEEN
THERE.
IS THERE SOMEBODY IN THE
CHAMBERS ITS REPERTOIRE CENTER
BILL RIGHT THERE.
SENATE BILL COMING UP WE WILL.
GONNA GO WITH.
S. B..
FIVE ONE NINE SENATE ALL REMIND
RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU --
FOR THAT.
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR
HARD WORK --
THIS BILL SIMPLY ALLOWS CALTRANS
THE INTERNET LEASES WITH THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
AND THE CITY OF SAN JOSE A RATE
OF DOLLARS PER YEAR FOR MERCY
HOMELESS SHELTERS --
AND FEEDING PROGRAMS AND UNDER
THEIR CURRENT LAW CALTRANS HAS
THE AUTHORITY. TO ENTER INTO
SIMILAR LEASES WITH WHO --
SOME LOCAL JURISDICTIONS --
WE ARE GOING TO USE THIS.
TO DEVELOP AN ACTION PLAN.
FOR DEALING WITH THE HOMELESS
AND URGING AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I DID HAVE A
POWER POINT PRESENTATION BUT FOR
THE SAKE OF BREVITY ALAN RICKMAN
GAS WILL GO PROVIDED.
YOU MAY SAM LICCARDO THEY'D.
THANK YOU.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT LOGAN MR
ROVE [inaudible]
S. TRAVEL [inaudible]
MORE MEN.
ANY MEMBERS THE PUBLIC LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
AUTHORS BILL.
ANY MEMBERS THE PUBLIC LIKE
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION AUTHORS
BILL ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
THAT'S A GOOD BILL.
MISTER BELL WOULD YOU LIKE TO OF
CLOSE.
THE JAWBONE THEM.
CENTER BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR HAVE YOU SEE FOR THE
HOMELESS.
INDIVIDUALS IN OUR STATE AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING YOU'RE A
CHAMPION IN MANY WAYS SO.
I'LL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
TODAY --
MEDI [inaudible]
FIRST FROM.
GIPSON SECOND BY MISTER BERMAN.
BAD SECTOR PLEASE CULTURAL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS FRAZIER.
I AYE FRAZIER AYE FONG.
FONG NOT LETTING AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BAKER.
BAKER NO BERMAN BERMAN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE A DAILY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AYE GIPSON GIPSON AYE
HARPER.
HARPER NO MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MEDINA.
MEDINA INEZ ARYAN.
NAZARIAN AYE O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL I THAT'S TEN TO THREE
YEAR BILLS OUT THANK YOU MISTER
BELL RICHER HAVE GOOD EVENING.
SO OUR LAST ONE WE'RE GONNA
CALL.
BECAUSE GOING GENERIC.
GYMNASIUM BEATRIZ.
MS GARNER.
NEWBIE TESTIFYING FOR SENATOR
[inaudible]
KATHLEEN [inaudible]
CHAIR [inaudible]
AND MEMBERS.
PLEASE PERCENT OF THINGS ARE
VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENTS THIS BUILT HERE
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE THIRTY BY.
ASSEMBLYMAN BIGELOW --
IN THIS BILL IS ON BEHALF OF THE
RV TRADE INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
AND I HAVE WITH ME TODAY MIKE.
MIKE BELOW.
PREP THEIR INDUSTRY.
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR VERY BRIEFLY THE BILL
MERELY PERMITS AT HISTORIC
NATIONAL TRECHO TO MOVE FROM.
THAT POMONA TO THE AUTO CLUB
SPEEDWAY IN FONTANA WHICH WE
HAVE NO OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE OTHER AUTHORS BILL MISTER
WELK WAS LIKE TO TEST FILE SO
[inaudible]
YEAH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ELECTED TESTIFYING
OPPOSITION.
DOLLARS BILL.
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE OF
THE AUTHOR.
WHICH LIKE CLOSE.
I'D JUST REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A WE HAVE A
FIRST MASCULINE.
HE USED TO IT.
LEGENDARY THIRTY THREE YEARS.
YEAH RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A FIRST
BY MISTER PHONE SEX MY MISTER
BERMAN MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THAT THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRENT AND
FRAZIER FRAZIER AYE FONG AYE
FONG AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN I CHIU.
CHIU AYE DALY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MEDINA.
MEDINA INEZ AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE.
THAT'S FOURTEEN ZERO YOU'RE GOOD
TO GO THANK YOU AND
CONGRATULATIONS.
SO THANK YOU SO WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND LIFT ANY CALLS THAT WE
HAVE [inaudible]
MADAM SECRETARY.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE O'DONNELL O'DONNELL
AYE FINAL VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
FOURTEEN TO ZERO FILE ITEM TO A.
B. NINETY ONE CURRENT VOTERS
TWELVE TO ZERO THERE'S ARYAN.
NAZARIAN I'VE FINAL VOTE.
THIRTEEN TO ZERO FILE ITEM FIVE
AB THIRTY SIXTY ONE CURRENT VOTE
THIRTEEN TO ZERO IN THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE FINAL VOTE.
FOURTEEN TO ZERO SO IT COULD UP
ON ALL OF THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
IT'S LIKE JUST LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE IS NOW
COMPLETE THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED